le drapeau ukrainien flotte à nouveau
sur kharkiv dans la deuxième ville
d'ukraine quelques signes apparaissent
d'une vie qui reprend ici vivaient plus
d'un million d'habitants avant la guerre
la municipalité estime que plus de 95%
des gens présents aujourd'hui à kharkiv
sont d'anciens réfugiés revenus chez eux
la situation dans la ville est compliqué
prenez les gens reviennent tout le monde
a le mal du pays moi aussi j'ai ramené
ma famille récemment ce qu'on est tous
fatigués de vivre à l'étranger c'est
assez dur d'être un réfugié
après trois mois de guerre une
occupation russe et des combats encore
en cours dans la périphérie de la ville
est les dégâts sont nombreux et visible
par tous la population s'organise pour
commencer à nettoyer et à réparer fait
du metas weber-gobet au septième étage
vous voyez le trou sur le balcon
un obus est tombé mais il n'a pas
explosé ça n'a pas brûlé mais tout a été
détruit on a plus d'appartements dans
les trois pièces on a pris ce qu'on
pouvait récupérer et on a tout mis dans
les voitures
marchent beaucoup ne sont venus que pour
ramener quelques affaires lors logements
sont inhabitables
c'est le cas de cet homme dont la
famille est restée à l'étranger
ici c'était une zone interdite au civil
quand je suis revenu et que j'ai vu ça
c'est tellement dommage je suis triste
parce que j'ai vécu ici avec ma femme et
ma fille chassaigne
ces derniers jours à kharkiv le métro a
aussi rouvert la municipalité veut ainsi
faciliter la reprise de l'économie sur
le plan symbolique elle entend des rues
si fier les rues certaines au nom
évoquant la russie ont déjà été
rebaptisé